how long should you code for pretty
vague question what do you mean like
over your lifetime in a day per session
let's talk about per session
that's probably what people are
wondering but we'll also talk about
other things maybe - like where this
orange came from tree there solve that
well if you're asking how long of a
session should I code for your eye I
think then you're asking the wrong
question now if you would ask me this
months ago I would have said four to six
hours is usually good I don't think
that's actually the right answer I think
the right answer is do you know what
you're going to do you know what to code
is if you don't if you don't have a plan
then the answer should be zero
you shouldn't code you should instead
try to come up with a plan or a model
for what you're going to do so once you
have an idea of what you want to attain
then you should start coding how long
should you cook for well everybody's
different the general answer is until
it's until your thing is done or you
can't can't take it anymore until you're
really tired as soon as you start
feeling tired or zoned out you should
take a break one trick to have a really
productive time once you already know
what you're going to do is to take a nap
or to take a walk a walk really works
well because you get your blood
circulating again and think it's your
brain thinking and you often things
would come to you that you didn't think
of we're just sitting there staring at
your screen and it's sort of the same
asleep except rather than blood flowing
it's like brain recharging so maybe it's
a combination of both NASA food rest
come back to it but ultimately if you
have a task in mind and a goal in mind
you're gonna be coding until it's done
however long that takes you sometimes
you can get that one done in one day
I've heard people say that once they
have a project they work on it basically
non-stop until it's done sometimes up to
20 hour coding sessions I'm sure they
have breaks in there and stuff but I
have heard people say that and that's
how they do their thing and they get
clients and they get they get chops on
their own and they knock them out like
that and then they take long breaks from
coding they might not code again until
they get another client or another
project I personally like to try to code
some every day but also
you really do need to have a task and
there are plenty of them out there you
can come up with your own thing you can
try to find a client you could try to
work on someone else's thing or if you
just want exercises you can go online
and do a few problems there or find some
challenges there too to do so maybe this
is a little vague but just to be clear
you should have a task set out in front
of you first and you should have some
guidelines and some goals to meet and
that should determine how long you're
gonna code for it shouldn't be some set
amount of time although it might just be
a set amount of time like if you're at a
job and you need to put in four hours it
might be four hours of coding it might
be one hour of planning three hours of
coding or you know it's gonna be
different than pre time but you can't
really just sit down in code without
anything to actually work on with just
I'm programming
what are you programming that's a better
question well that's gonna do it for
this video I hope you enjoyed and see
you the next one